make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay those guys who are gonna be going
to Emerald City Comicon this year I will
be there roaming around I'll be with
Mariah and we'll be going to check stuff
out not doing any panels or anything
really going is just kind of checking
out the con floor and so on and so forth
all that kind of good stuff but you may
see me roaming around so yeah I don't
know if I'll have Rob core rings on me
at all
but you'll probably see me roaming
around there so just FYI okay so getting
into the price of justice the Batman and
flash crossover this is the second one
they've done and it's actually really
coolest Joshua Williamson and Tom King
but what this story is is this this is
not like the button right like the
button it was like a prelude to really
focusing on like the Watchmen in really
when you were a prelude was more of like
kind of going a little more in-depth
into like what was going on with the
button and it was kind of setting the
stage for like DC teasing and saying yes
you know Jay Garrick is still alive but
he's stuck in the speedforce different
things like that this story is what we
as couple book readers call a transition
story a transition story is a story that
usually comes out of an existing set of
events in this instance the middle of
heroes in crisis and then in turn sets
the stage early kind of transitions the
DC landscape in a new direction in this
case the year of the villains now as far
as I'm aware it's kind of weird you're
the villains from DC almost kind of
looks like a new 52 villains month but
instead of being like a series of one
shots based on villains it's kind of
setting the stage for like a whole new
total shift with regards to like
everything DC's doing for 2019
fun fact um for a free comic book day
the Wednesday before free couple of a
day I think DC's publishing a one-shot
you're the villains number one which is
like 25 cents you guys should all go buy
that comic it's 25 cents if you have 25
cents to buy comic I don't know what to
tell you but nonetheless um what this
does is again this kind of comes out of
heroes in crisis so it's not as though
it takes place after heroes and crisis
is done it kind of ties into it but it's
also somewhat standalone now there are a
couple of things that we do need to know
but really like the big thing to Nami
you can read heroes in crisis number one
and be fine because it's like the death
of Wally West just like the big thing
that happened here but what also happens
is this basically kind of a wrapping up
of plot threads specifically with like
Gotham and Gotham girl for those who
guys remember those characters and will
cross you know do some explanation once
we get to them you know once we cross
that bridge but in the moment right now
is really Batman facing off against like
a bunch of Amazo robots alongside the
rest of the Justice League but it's
really just kind of designed to show
what the Justice League is doing in the
fact that so many
been going on at the same time now
that's the basis behind heroes in crisis
I mean really there's a whole idea of
like heroes who have been killed and so
on and so forth but the notion behind
this between Scot Snyder's Justice
League between Tom Kings heroes in
crisis between the Batman comic in the
flash comic the heroes have basically
been non-stop like there's been like
five major crises they've dealt with in
the last week and they're constantly
running almost all the time but so is
Batman and Batman's really gonna push
really pushing himself to the limit more
than anybody else and this really comes
to a head when like somebody attacked
the flash museum and of course Batman
responds and then yo Barry Allen shows
up to help him kind of figure out who it
is but the discussion between the two of
them is that Batman had you know having
pushed himself to the extreme is almost
in a position to where he can't really
think rationally or clearly now for the
most part and this is a scenario where
flash begins to question Bruce Wayne
like where he begins to question Batman
the idea behind Bruce Wayne's character
in the DC mythos is that he's one of the
smartest men out there right like as the
reader people know that but even within
DC Comics it's the idea of like Batman's
the world's greatest detective the other
members of the Justice League know that
Batman's more than capable of holding
his own and he's kind of the guy they go
to you whenever they can't figure
something out but one of the things that
very honorably hits at and really kind
of coming out of the death of Wally West
is like there's too many unsolved
mysteries there for the world's greatest
detective there's a lot of things Batman
has it been able to figure out yet
there's a lot of mysteries that are
going on there now in reality Barry
Allen's kind of being a little unfair
here but at the same time it is a
truthful statement but the other part of
this is that for the most part it's
Batman being being in a scenario where
the answer he's trying to attain are
beyond his ability to gain right like we
know that like dr. Manhattan is pretty
much screwed up the DC universes grand
experiment ever he wants to be but
there's no way Batman will be able to
deduce that because it's so far beyond
the realm of possibilities there's no
reason he would jump jump to that
logical conclusion Batman focuses more
on the tangible and the reality of
scenarios as opposed to how things could
how things could possibly unfold in
terms of just like bonkers ideologies
but in terms of what's going on here
Batman kind of spills the beans about
Gotham girl and for the most part Gotham
girl in Gotham a really almost kind of
like Batman's dirty little secret now
for those you guys you don't know about
that when Tom Kane first started his
Batman run you had I am Gotham and then
like it was the I am series right so
it's like I am Gotham I am Bane all that
kind of good stuff
I am Gotham introduced Gotham and Gotham
girl and there were basically two people
who were
whose family were saved by that and when
they were younger and they grew up to
idolize the Justice League and so
somewhere along the line through means
by which haven't been fully explained
they were somehow able to attain extreme
levels of power but the more they used
their power the more their bodies burn
out now this led to like psycho-pirate
using his ability to manipulate emotions
and kind of driving them insane
ultimately Gotham ended up losing his
mind and then was killed in the process
and then Gotham girl was so extremely
screwed up that Batman literally
sidelined her but the argument that
Batman had presented to everybody even
when the Justice League like face off
against Gotham and so on the argument he
presented here was I benched her because
I don't want her to use up her powers
but what he really comes out and says is
the whole reason behind why he benched
her is he doesn't want her to end up
like him he doesn't want her to end up
following in his own path but the other
part of this is that for Gotham girl
well we don't know exactly what's going
on here what we do know is that she
seems to basically be manipulated by
somebody else because what they've done
is they've essentially brought her
brother back or the very least he can
basically be revived and that's kind of
the crazy scenario here because the
question is being asked is one
why is Gotham girl doing all this and
two if Gotham is resurrected then in
turn what's the grand scheme here and so
of course using a few clues and here and
there you know Batman and flash pick up
on like a leaf that Gotham girl left
behind that was all like her shoe or
something like that and basically trace
it to a location because you know like
flashes of CSI and Batman's you know
Batman as Batman you know so we can you
can do whatever the plot demands and and
the cool thing about this is that once
they arrive there on the scene when they
get into where Gotham girl where her
base of operations seem to be it is a
kind of obsession room now this is one
of the things about Gotham girl and this
is one of the things about Gotham
himself is that initially it was
believed to be that they were just
characters who look to the Justice
League and said gosh they're awesome I'd
love to be like them one day as we
learned more about Gotham girl what we
learned was that it was extreme what
this does is basically capitalize on
that and say like when they looked at
Batman and the Justice League what they
saw weird as they wanted to be like they
literally wanted to be like them but the
whole basis behind this is that we're
flash says well hey maybe she's just as
crazy as eobard thawne was right you
know like reverse-flash wanted to
replace Barry Allen he wanted to be the
new flash he wanted to literally be
Barry that's why he made himself look
like Barry and so on and so forth that
as response is it's not that she's
insane it's that she wanted to be what
she thought a hero was but she was
literally trying to be a hero
and that's the problem with her
that Batman's Batman stances I didn't
want her to be the same kind of person I
was but it's one of these scenarios
where the more Batman kept her on the
sidelines and the more Batman kept her
from being a hero the more extreme her
desire to become a hero became and so it
basically pushed her to the limit to the
point where she was literally doing
whatever she needed to do to essentially
be a hero and so as they go through and
they investigate things what they find
out is that by some strange manner again
that's not fully explained now there's
basically all these giant test tubes
that are out there where Gotham girl
presumably alongside somebody else has
been going through and trying to create
new Gotham's like her own Justice League
more or less and it's kind of a cool
little thing here because where flash
looks at this from the perspective of
this is a crime scene let's figure out
what's going on Batman looks at it looks
at it for more of like a sinister
perspective someone's led us here
somebody wanted us to find all this and
that's the crazy scenario is because
suddenly Barry starts sort of drawing
these conclusion he starts drawing these
parallels he starts thinking about the
idea of sanctuary and what he does is he
says if the whole basis behind Bethel
the whole base behind sanctuary was for
those individuals who were heroes who
were struggling with whatever they were
struggling with to go and then in turn
get the help they need it did Batman
send Gotham girl there and if Batman
sent Gotham girl there he had to know he
sent a mentally unstable person to a
place where other heroes work with the
possibility existing she could lose her
mind and kill everybody and so in the
mind of of Barry Allen even if he
doesn't quite outright say it he's sort
of hinting at the idea that Batman sent
Gotham girl to sanctuary Gotham girl
killed everyone Batman got all the
superheroes killed including Wally West
doesn't really say this in so many words
it's more or less common idea that Hugh
throws out there but it's interesting to
see because we're the two of them are
basically met with the arrival of Gotham
girl who's toting like a giant bottle of
venom the basis kind of seems to be here
that Bane is the one behind this and
that's why I scope this sort of cool
here because of course again in the
middle of all this Gotham basically
makes his return and Gotham faces off
against Batman but the I guess bat and
in flash but the other part of this it
is a whole host of these various you
know Gotham and Gotham girls who were
who were fighting off against them it's
Batman flash versus an army of Superman
but the fact remains here that with
Batman and flash facing off against
these you know these Gotham's Batman
comes up with the idea he essentially
says like make them use their powers in
the extreme run as fast as you possibly
can and they'll have to use every ounce
of power they have just to keep up and
again that'll burn their bodies out
it's the weakness of the Gotham's but
from here eventually you know like like
flash effectively catches up with you
know Gotham when she I'm sorry Gotham
girl when she races off to Central City
of course you know attacking iris West
in the process it's it's kind of crazy
because Batman initially tries to real
Barry Allen in like we can't just go
racing over this girl we have to gain
information but this is something I want
you guys to notice here Barry Allen is
not acting like his normal self ever
since the death of Wally West Barry
Allen's kind of snapped to a degree
right like that's kind of what's been
going on in his own flash comics and
that's kind of what's been going on here
and during the events of heroes in
crisis is that Barry Allen's just sort
of lost it and so he's acting very
uncharacteristic in terms of how you
normally expect to see him under normal
circumstances he would have just raced
off after Gotham girl that usually
wouldn't have happened he would have
wanted to but when Batman pulled him
back and said hey look we need to gather
information we need to figure out what's
going on he would have acquiesced and
said yes you're right let's do it let's
look at this from a scientific
perspective and then kind of go from
there because of this was very sort of
racing off to the scene like that what
he does is try to start speaking
directly to Gotham grow propert and
essentially saying hey look I understand
what you're trying to do and become a
hero but here's the problem that you
face is that the price we pay for being
a hero is exceedingly high and that's
one of the things that he talked about
with Wally he basically says like I
blame myself for the death of Wally West
I knew that Wally would not have
listened to me if I told him do not
follow in my footsteps and so because
that I just never told him but very kind
of ask himself the question what if I
did though like what if I told Wally do
not do what I do do not become a
superhero like me go find your own way
in the world how would things have
turned out would Wally still be alive
but Gotham girl kind of responds and
says I don't really know what you're
talking about my brother's back here
like my brother's back and my brother's
alive and so Gotham is essentially here
and so again it's crazy because it's
Supergirl is essentially like a
Supergirl in a Superman versus flash and
Batman and again like they are easily
overpowered because the last time Gotham
was here he crushed the Justice League
like he single-handedly held his own
against the entirety of the Justice
League but that's when the caveat sort
of comes in is because where Batman's
racing there in his in his bat jet as
fast as he possibly can in order to save
the life of Barry Allen in the middle of
this whole fight Gotham's body burns out
in the blink of an eye and that's when
it's kind of hint at that Gotham girl
was duped and that's what again when the
whole plot thread began to kind of wrap
up and Tom King sort of writes Gotham
girl out of the equation what he
basically has her do the exact same
thing
ultimately she just kind of burns
herself out she says like you know if I
could die a hero you know if I can if I
can die like a bright hero as opposed to
just sort of sitting on the sitting in
the background and just fading away
isn't that worth it and so she literally
this kind of maximizes her power use the
full totality of her abilities and
starts facing off against Batman in
flash and so at this point it's really
them just kind of playing a waiting game
and so with this unformed the way it
does she kind of burns out her powers
essentially like snap that's that's
really the end of that she basically
seems to die when that happens again the
plot thread is kind of wrapped up in
like their desire and really keeping her
on the back burner when Barry Allen he
sort of uses his powers to like speed up
his momentum and then effectively
jumpstart her heart and when that
happens it brings her back but Batman
begins to look at her and say the
problem that he made the mistake he made
was keeping her on the back burner so
again transitioning into the new
direction of Gotham girl in the Batman
comics and Batman basically going
through and saying let's let her be a
hero you know essentially but that's
kind of a cool thing it's following this
Barry Allen Batman have this
conversation Barry Allen asked Batman
the question what are you gonna do about
Gotham girl and Batman says I'm gonna
take her under my wing and I'm gonna
teach her how to be a hero and Barry's
response is but what if she snaps again
and Batman's response is well then we're
gonna be there to stop her but if she
wants to be a hero it's not my place to
tell her that she can't and that's where
Barry Allen begins to kind of lose it
and he says that's the problem that you
have that's the price that we have for
being a hero everybody that we know and
love gets pulled into this and Batman
kind of ashes by saying but like we pay
this price so that our loved ones don't
have to and it's kind of cool because
Barry's response is but they do anyway
we as superheroes pay the price on what
it means to be a hero running ourselves
to a jaw exhaustion never really being
able to have a normal life this is the
price that we pay to be a hero but we do
that so that our families our loved ones
our brothers sisters husbands wives so
they can sleep at night but then
suddenly Wally West dies and then
suddenly it's but no matter what I do
that people I love get hurt anyway so is
this price really worth it and he kind
of makes this slide against Batman you
know innocent people are always put in
the crossfire
anybody could die maybe another Robin
could die and that's when Batman kind of
lashes out and says what at least I
never forgot one of my partner's existed
and that's when Barry like snaps just
absolutely loses it and it's the coolest
thing to see because like these bat
these bat defenses activate and
literally Barry comes running at Batman
as fast as he possibly can and
like ghosts to punch him but stops and
it's the coolest line in the world
because he says I could have hit you a
hundred times before you threw one punch
but as one of these things where Joshua
Williams is just kinda like hey so like
for those guys out there who kind of are
a little unsure about the flash let me
remind you of his place in the bigger
picture by the grace of the flash goes
the Justice League and it's a cool
little thing and so in the aftermath of
all this when when the two of them kind
of have this this bit of a fight between
each other and of course like flash
races off you know it says look like I'm
not you I don't solve my problems
through like anger and rage or anything
along those lines I try to keep my keep
my cool I try to be reasonable you know
he kind of races off and does his own
thing that Batman basically calls him
Superman and says look like there's too
many mysteries here there's too many
people not acting the way they're
normally supposed to there's too many
things going on here too many questions
that haven't been answered and too many
things that need to be figured out why
is everything changed why are 10 years
gone from our montt why is all of this
happening we have to focus on these
heroes and figure out which one of them
is not who they claim to be kind of
setting up the idea that someone behind
the scene that's not dr. Manhattan is
pulling the strings and manipulating
everyone and so bringing Superman in the
first thing that Batman says is the way
this flash has been acting this entire
time the way the flash has been
conducting himself how how quick he is
to anger all this indicates that either
this is not very Allen or Barry Allen's
being manipulated but something's wrong
here that we cannot trust anyone but
ourselves
we're being tricked it's pretty cool but
again like it all sets the stage for
like DC's year of the villain but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comment explain make sure you guys
are the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace